julián escutia rodríguez consul of
mexico in las vegas if not town a
little bit about
and this is the third time that we open a
first dose vaccination day
today we have facer here at the consulate
of mexico and it is something very important
because we send the message to the
community  that Hispanics should be vaccinated, they
were the most affected by the
pandemic, high levels of contagion and even
low levels of vaccination, so
the vaccine is very important along
with prevention so that we emerge
stronger from this pandemic, the
effort continues to be everywhere
in the community for the first one in the
community because of the problem is that what we
are seeing now is happening
health officials since the
people who are going to be vaccinated have already been vaccinated
and now the people who do not want to be
vaccinated are the ones who are  trying to
direct the message to them and in the
people who need that is the 12
to attract to area
since the vaccine was going to be
available no  We began to
participate in information campaigns,
we held workshops and we continue
to hold online workshops so that people know
and I heard from the experts that the vaccine
is safe, it is free, they do not ask
anything about migration, there is no need to be
afraid about this vaccine and also to
Comment on the importance of the second
dose depending on whether it is modern or facer. It
is the number of days after it
should be given and if it is not done, well,
one almost returns to the point where it started,
so you have to take the
first dose again and then  Now, if we comply
with the second, it is better that we do everything
in order so that together, as I was saying,
we come out stronger from this pandemic
than to buy this movement a little.
of
exercise
asking which one they are going to
put me is safe not
in the consulate we have only had
modern fighter iv yes people few
ask about joh's  nson but the
US and world authorities have been
very clear that the vaccine is safe
so you should not be afraid if the
authorities are making
the vaccines available it is because they are safe
the next date in French to give
vaccines
when you do  the next one
you wanted
on Tuesday May 18th we invite all
the people who came today to not
miss it and take your second dose the
simplest one
is very easy but what are the
requirements
none of you want to get ahead of this
pandemic and bring an ID it
doesn't matter  which
photo identification is more than welcome it
is very important that all those
eligible get the vaccine everyone
over 16 please get the
vaccine because only then will we get
ahead